Ben wants to implement a smoothing operation on a 4096 element one-dimensional array
This array is indexed by i and the value at each index is V [ i ].
The smoothing operation on element i = 0.25 x V [i - 1] + 0.5 x V [ i ] + 0.25 x V [ i + 1].
And a quick note.
At the boundary, assume that all values beyond the boundary
like V [-1] or V [4096] are equal to the value at that boundary, V [0] or V [4095].
The new values, Vnew [ i ] at each step can be computed in parallel.
Then Vnew becomes V, and we continue.
Ben wants to implement this in CUDA.
He wants to launch 4096 threads to solve this problem, and he decides to launch 16 blocks of 256 threads each.
And here is Ben's code.
Ben says his code works but is running much slower than he would like.
So rewrite Ben's code to increase the speed.
In particular, can you reduce the number of global memory transfers?